بالنسبه لي يعني في جانب عاطفي فعلا في
موضوع الزفه كون والده العروس
السيده عزه ستيري يعني ابنه الحاره وابنه
القريات وتربينا سويا في نفس الحاره وفي
نفس المنطقه وكان والدها امير منطقه
القريات الله يرحمه الامير نايف بن عبد
العزيز وكان والدي مدير الشرطه ففي روابط
من ايام الطفوله ارتباطي العاطفي او
الجانب النفسي في هذا الموضوع اسهم كثيرا
في انه القصيده تطلع من القلب ومن الاعماق
اضافه الى علاقه يعني ربطتني في فتره من
فترات مع جلاله الملك حسين الله يرحمه وجد
العريس والتقينا اكثر من مره في دور في
لندن وايضا مع الملك عبد الله الثاني
التقيته حسن الخلق والذوق الرفيع
والانسانيه الجميله ايضا
اكادير بداخلي وانا اكتب زفاف ولي العهد
بالعين بين الرمش والرمش يا حسين
شفنا القمر ساطع وشفناه رجوه
[موسيقى]
العلاقه السعوديه الاردنيه علاقه ممتده
وطويله التاريخيه
حتى في العادات وفي التقاليد وفي الحدود
والمشتركه الى جانب انه العرس عرس سعودي
اردني
فتربطنا حتى في موضوع الفلكلور وموضوع
اللهجه العاميه وموضوع الطبائع اشياء
كثيره فكان من الطبيعي انه يكون هذاك
الانسجام اللي حدث ما بين محمد عبده وعمر
العبد الله واثنين اصدقاء من من البدايه
تقريبا يعني محمد عبده غنالي كثير من
الزفات والمناسبات الوطنيه من 30 سنه
تقريبا وعمر من بداياته تغنى بكثير من
اعمالي من حوالي 20 سنه واكثر
فالموضوع كان يعني ما كان في صعوبه
حاولنا من خلال النص ان نوجد رابطه اسريه
واحده وكان اللي تزوجوا من اسره واحده ما
حاولنا نبعد او نفرق وهذي دوله من ثقافه
وهذا من ثقافه بالعكس مثل ما شاف الجميع
كان في انسجام تام بين الاثنين عمر
ومحمد عبده وفي الناس ايضا حاولنا ان يكون
هناك جو موحد
وهذه الحقيقه وهذا الدور الفن ان يوحد بين
الشعوب وان يقارب بين الجميع
الشعور الواحد يعتز فيه ويفتخر انه اسهم
في هذا اللقاء وهذا
خلينا نسميه الحفل الملكي يبقى كان لتجارب
سابقا مع الاستاذ محمد عبده في زفات ملكيه
مختلفه ولكن هذا ان اعتقد انه من اميز ما
عملنا في هذا الاتجاه خاصه بانه يجمع
بلدين قريبين على قلبي
وطرفين سمو الامير الحسين
وسمو الامير رجوه كلهم قريبين من القلب
ومن العاطفه وبالتالي احس بسعاده ونسوه
حقيقيه
ومثل ما شاهد الجميع هناك نوع من
الفرحه حتى البعيدين يعني الكل مفارق بهذه
المناسبه ونتمنى ان شاء الله ان تدوم
الافراح